Permettez-moi de vous montrer des images
de ce que selon moi seront les villes de demain.
Donc, voilà Kibera, la plus grande communauté de squatters à Nairobi.
Voici la communauté de squatters au Parc National Sanjay Gandhi
à Bombay, en Inde, qu'on appelle Mumbai de nos jours.
Voici Hosinia, la favela la plus grande et la plus urbanisée
de Rio de Janeiro.
Et voici Sultanbelyi,
qui est l'une des plus grandes communautés de squatters à Istanbul.
Selon moi, ce sont les villes de demain,
le nouveau monde urbain.
Alors, pourquoi est-ce que je dis ça ?
Pour vous le dire, je dois vous parler de ce type ici,
il s'appelle Julius.
Et j'ai rencontré Julius la dernière semaine de mon séjour à Kibera.
Donc, j'étais là depuis presque trois mois,
et je tournais dans la ville en me rendant dans les différents secteurs du bidonville
et Julius me suivait, et il avait les yeux exorbités
et à certains moments quand nous marchions,
il saisissait ma main pour trouver un soutien,
et c'est un geste que la plupart des Kenyans n'envisageraient jamais de faire.
Ils sont très polis et ils ne deviennent pas si hardis si vite.
Et j'ai découvert plus tard que c'était le premier jour de Julius à Nairobi,
et ils sont nombreux comme lui.
Donc, près de 200 000 personnes par jour
migrent des zones rurales vers les zones urbaines.
Et je vais être juste avec les statisticiens
qui ont parlé ce matin, ce n'est pas 1,5 million de gens par semaine,
mais presque 1,4 million de gens par semaine, mais je suis journaliste,
et nous exagérons, donc presque 1,5 million de gens par semaine,
près de 70 millions par an.
Et si vous faites le calcul, ça fait 130 personnes par minute.
Donc ça fait -- dans les 18 minutes de la conférence que je donne ici,
entre 2 et 3 000 personnes auront fait le voyage vers les villes.
Et voici les statistiques.
Aujourd'hui -- un milliard de squatters,
une personne sur six sur la planète.
2030 -- deux milliards de squatters,
une personne sur quatre sur la planète.
Et on estime qu'en 2050, il y aura trois milliards de squatters.
Plus d'une personne sur trois sur terre.
Donc ce sont les villes du futur, et nous devons nous en occuper.
Et je pensais ce matin à la belle vie,
et avant que je vous montre le reste de ma présentation,
je vais enfreindre les règles de TED ici,
et je vais vous lire un passage de mon livre aussi vite que possible.
Parce que je pense qu'il évoque comment changer notre perception
de ce que nous considérons comme la belle vie.
Donc -- "La hutte était faite de tôle ondulée, posée sur une dalle de béton.
C'était une cellule de 10 par 10.
Armstrong O'Brian Jr. la partageait avec trois autres hommes.
Armstrong et ses amis n'avaient pas d'eau,
ils en achetaient à un voisin qui possédait un robinet.
Pas de toilettes, les familles dans cette enceinte partageaient une latrine avec un trou
et n'avaient ni égouts ni sanitaires.
Ils avaient l'électricité,
mais c'était un service illégal branché sur les câbles de quelqu'un d'autre,
et ne pouvaient alimenter qu'une seule faible ampoule.
C'était Southland, un petit bidonville
du côté ouest de Nairobi, au Kenya.
Mais ç'aurait pu être n'importe où dans la ville,
parce que plus de la moitié de la ville de Nairobi vit de cette manière.
Un million et demi de gens entassés dans des huttes de boue ou de métal
sans services, sans toilettes, sans droits.
Armstrong a expliqué la réalité brutale de leur situation,
ils payaient 1 500 shillings de loyer, environ 20 dollars par mois,
un prix relativement élevé pour un bidonville kenyan,
et ils ne pouvaient pas se permettre de retard dans les paiements.
'Si vous devez un mois, le propriétaire viendra avec ses acolytes
et il vous expulsera. il confisquera vos affaires,' a dit Armstrong.
'Pas un mois, un jour,' a ajouté son colocataire Hilary Kibagendi Onsomu,
qui cuisinait du ugali, une bouillie de maïs blanc
qui est l'aliment de base dans le pays.
Ils appelaient leur propriétaire un Wabenzi, ce qui signifie qu'il est
quelqu'un avec assez d'argent pour rouler en Mercedes-Benz.
Hilary a servi le ugali avec un mélange frit de viande et de tomates,
le soleil tapait sur le mince toit d'acier,
et nous transpirions en mangeant.
Le repas terminé, Armstrong a rajusté sa cravate,
enfilé une veste de sport en laine, et est parti dans la lumière éblouissante.
Dehors un monticule d'ordures formait la frontière
entre Southland et le quartier légal voisin de Langata.
Il mesurait peut-être 2,5 mètres de haut, 12 mètres de long, et 3 mètres de large.
Et il était au milieu d'une mare de vase.
Alors que nous passions devant, deux garçons escaladaient le mont Kenya d'ordures.
Ils n'avaient pas plus de 5 ou 6 ans.
Ils étaient pieds nus, et à chaque pas leurs orteils s'enfonçaient dans la saleté
faisant s'envoler des centaines de mouches du tas rance.
Je pensais qu'ils jouaient à qui arriverait le premier en haut, mais je me trompais.
Une fois en haut du tas, l'un des garçons a baissé son short,
s'est accroupi, et a déféqué.
Les mouches bourdonnaient autour de ses jambes.
Quand 20 familles -- 100 personnes environ -- partagent une seule latrine,
un garçon qui fait caca sur un tas d'ordures n'a peut-être pas d'importance.
Mais c'était un contraste saisissant
avec quelque chose qu'Armstrong avait dit pendant que nous mangions --
qu'il tenait beaucoup à la qualité de vie dans son quartier.
Pour Armstrong, Southland n'était pas entravé par ses conditions matérielles.
Au lieu de ça, un esprit d'humanité irradiait
des murs de métal et des tas d'ordures pour offrir quelque chose
qu'aucun quartier légal ne peut offrir -- la liberté.
'On est facilement accro à cet endroit,' avait-il dit.
'C'est une vie simple, mais personne ne vous limite.
Personne ne contrôle ce que vous faites.
Quand vous avez séjourné ici, vous ne pouvez plus partir.'
Il voulait dire partir au-delà de cette montagne d'ordures,
retourner dans la ville légale, dans les bâtiments légaux,
avec des loyers légaux et des droits légaux.
‘Quand vous avez séjourné ici', a-t-il dit,
vous pouvez rester jusqu'à la fin de vos jours."
Donc, il a de l'espoir, et c'est là que commencent ces communautés.
Voici peut-être le bidonville le plus primitif qu'on peut trouver à Kibera,
guère plus qu'une hutte de bâtons et de boue à côté d'un tas d'ordures.
Voici comment on se prépare à la mousson à Bombay en Inde.
Voici l'amélioration de l'habitat.
Mettre des bâches en plastique sur votre toit.
C'est Rio de Janeiro, et c'est un peu mieux, non ?
Ce que nous voyons, ce sont des tuiles en terre cuite et des bouts de panneaux récupérés
et du plâtre par dessus la brique, de la couleur,
et c'est la maison de Sulay Montakaya à Sultanbelyi, et c'est encore mieux.
Il a une clôture, il a récupéré une porte.
Il a de nouvelles tuiles sur son toit.
Et ensuite vous avez Rocinha
et vous pouvez voir que c'est encore mieux.
Les bâtiments ici ont plusieurs étages.
Ils se développent -- vous pouvez voir à l'extrême droite
un immeuble où on a l'impression qu'on en a empilé un au-dessus de l'autre,
pièce après pièce après pièce.
Et ce que les gens font c'est qu'ils développent leur habitat sur un ou deux étages,
et ils vendent leurs droits à la loggia ou au toit,
et quelqu'un d'autre construit par dessus leur construction,
et ensuite cette personne vend les droits de son toit,
et quelqu'un d'autre construit par dessus leur construction.
Toutes ces constructions sont en béton armé et en briques.
Et puis vous avez Sultanbelyi en Turquie, ou la construction
atteint un niveau encore plus élevé de design.
La crasse au premier plan c'est du rembourrage de matelas,
et vous en voyez dans toute la Turquie.
Les gens font sécher ou aèrent le rembourrage de leurs matelas sur leurs toits.
Mais l'immeuble vert derrière,
vous pouvez voir que le dernier étage est inoccupé,
donc les gens construisent avec la possibilité d'expansion.
Et c'est construit avec un niveau de design assez élevé.
Et puis finalement vous avez des habitations de squatters comme celle-ci,
qui est construit d'après le modèle banlieusard.
Et c'est la maison d'une seule famille dans la communauté de squatters.
C'est également à Istanbul en Turquie.
Ce sont des endroits plein de vie, ces communautés.
Voici la rue principale de Rocinha, la Estrada da Gavea,
et il y a une ligne de bus qui passe par là,
il y a beaucoup de gens dans la rue.
Ces communautés dans ces villes sont en fait plus vivantes
que les communautés illégales.
Il s'y passe plus de choses.
Voici une allée typique dans Rocinha appelée un beco --
c'est par là qu'on circule dans la communauté.
C'est sur une pente très raide.
Elles sont construites sur les collines, loin des plages de Rio à l'intérieur des terres,
et vous pouvez voir que les maisons sont simplement construites en porte à faux sur les obstacles naturels.
C'est juste un rocher sur le flanc de la colline.
Et ces becos sont normalement pleines de monde,
et les gens montent les meubles ou les réfrigérateurs, toutes sortes de choses
à dos d'homme par ces allées.
On amène la bière en la portant sur l'épaule.
La bière est une chose très importante au Brésil.
Voilà un commerce au Kenya, le long de la voie ferrée,
si près des rails que les marchands
doivent parfois tirer la marchandise hors du passage.
Voici une place de marché, également au Kenya, Toi Market,
de nombreux revendeurs, qui proposent presque tout ce que vous voulez acheter.
Ces choses vertes au premier plan sont des mangues.
Voici une rue commerçante à Kibera,
et vous pouvez voir qu'il y a un vendeur de soda, un dispensaire,
deux salons de beauté, un bar, deux épiceries, et une église et plus encore.
C'est une rue typique de centre ville, elle est juste auto-construite.
Ceci, à droite,
est ce qu'on appelle un -- si vous regardez les petits caractères sous l'auvent --
c'est un hôtel.
Et au Kenya et en Inde, hôtel signifie un endroit où on mange.
Donc, c'est un restaurant.
Les gens volent de l'électricité -- c'est à Rio.
Les gens se branchent et ils ont des voleurs appelés grillons ou criquets,
et ils volent l'électricité,
et connectent le quartier.
Les gens brûlent les ordures pour s'en débarrasser,
et ils creusent leurs propres canalisations d'égouts.
Les sacs plastiques sont plus abondants que du plancton,
et parfois ils ont un traitement d'ordures naturel.
Et quand ils ont de l'argent, ils cimentent leurs rues,
et ils installent des égouts et de bonnes canalisations pour l'eau, et des trucs comme ça.
C'est de l'eau qui va à Rio, les gens font passer leurs tuyaux d'eau partout,
et cette petite hutte là a une pompe, et voilà ce que font les gens.
ils volent de l'électricité, ils installent une pompe
et ils se branchent sur la canalisation principale d'eau, et ils pompent l'eau vers leurs maisons.
Donc la question est comment va-t-on d'un village de huttes en boue,
à une ville plus développée, et même à Sultanbelyi, hautement développée ?
Je dis qu'il y a deux choses.
La première est que les gens ont besoin d'être sûrs qu'ils ne seront pas expulsés.
Cela n'implique pas forcément des droits de propriété,
et je ne suis pas d'accord avec Hernando de Soto sur cette question,
parce que les droits de propriété créent beaucoup de complications,
ils sont le plus souvent vendus aux gens, et les gens se retrouvent endettés,
et ils doivent rembourser la dette,
et parfois ils doivent vendre leur propriété
pour payer leur dette.
Il y a un tas d'autres raisons pour lesquelles les droits de propriété
parfois ne fonctionnent pas dans ces cas-là,
mais ils n'ont pas besoin de la sécurité d'un titre de propriété.
Et ils ont besoin d'avoir accès à la politique, et ça peut vouloir dire deux choses.
ça peut vouloir dire que la communauté s'organise par le bas,
mais ça peut aussi vouloir dire des possibilités qui viennent d'en haut.
Et je dis ça parce que le système en Turquie est remarquable.
La Turquie a deux grandes lois qui protègent les squatteurs.
L'une est que -- elle s'appelle gecekondu en turc,
ce qui signifie construit du jour au lendemain, et si vous construisez votre maison du jour au lendemain
en Turquie, vous ne pouvez pas être expulsé sans un procès légal,
si vous n'êtes pas pris pendant la nuit.
Et le deuxième aspect est que dès qu'il y a 2000 personnes
dans la communauté, vous pouvez demander au gouvernement
qu'il vous reconnaisse comme une sous-municipalité légale.
Et quand vous êtes une sous-municipalité légale, d'un coup vous avez de la politique.
Vous êtes autorisé à avoir un gouvernement élu, à lever des impôts,
à fournir des services municipaux, et c'est exactement ce qu'ils font.
Donc, voici les leaders civils du futur.
La femme au milieu est Geeta Jiwa.
Elle vit dans une de ces tentes sur le terre-plein central de l'autoroute à Mumbai.
Voilà Sureka Gundi, elle vit aussi avec sa famille
dans la tente le long du même terre-plein d'autoroute.
Elles sont très directes. Elles sont très actives.
Elles peuvent être les leaders de la communauté.
Cette femme est Nine, ce qui signifie grand-mère en turc,
et il y avait trois vieilles dames qui vivaient dans --
c'est la maison qu'elle a construite elle-même derrière elle -- et elles ont vécu là pendant 30 ou 40 ans,
et elles sont les piliers de la communauté là-bas.
Voici Richard Muthama Peter,
il est photographe itinérant dans les rues à Kibera
Il gagne sa vie en prenant des photos du quartier,
et des gens du quartier
et il a un rôle important dans la communauté.
Et finalement le candidat à la mairie de Rio que je choisi est Cezinio,
le marchand de fruits avec ses deux enfants ici,
et je ne connais pas d'homme plus honnête, plus généreux et plus attentionné.
Le futur de ces communautés est dans les gens
et dans notre capacité à travailler avec ces gens.
Donc, je pense que le message que je prends, de ce que j'ai lu du livre,
de ce qu'Armstrong a dit, et de tous ces gens,
est que ce sont des quartiers.
La question n'est pas la pauvreté urbaine.
La question n'est pas s’il y a une voute ou pas à ces habitations.
La question est que nous devons reconnaître que ce sont des quartiers.
C'est une forme légitime de développement urbain,
et ces villes doivent faire face à ces résidents,
parce qu'ils construisent les villes du futur.
Merci beaucoup.